DEMOCRATS.
THE HOUSE AND SENATE ARE STILL
NARROWLY DIVIDED.
>> THANKS, CHAD.
THE FALLOUT FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
NOT THIS ONE, THE FORMER ONE.
DONALD TRUMP.
HE PICKED AND BACK AGGRESSIVELY
HERSCHEL WALKER.
A LOT OF CRITICISMS FROM
REPUBLICANS THAT HE WAS AN
UNWINNABLE CANDIDATE.
NOW WHAT HAPPENS TO DONALD TRUMP
AND HIS LEADERSHIP ROLE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
LET'S GO TO TOM DEVIN, LEE
CARTER HERE AS WELL.
LEE, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE IMPACT
ON ALL OF THIS FOR DONALD TRUMP.
>> WELL, I THINK WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS THE DAY BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
IN MANY WAYS, WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IS THAT DONALD TRUMP IS THE
HISTORY OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
NOT THE FUTURE.
I THINK THAT HE'S A BEEN VERY
CLEAR.
THE CANDIDATES THAT HE BACKED IN
VERY CLOSE RACES ENDED UP NOT
WINNING.
HIS STAR POWER, HIS MESSAGE
WASN'T ENOUGH TO CAT PUT PEOPLE
OVER THE FINISH LINE.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS CANDIDATES
LIKE DESANTIS AND KEMP THAT ARE
BUSINESS FRIENDLY, THAT HAVE
PLANS ON HOW TO MAKE -- THEY'RE
FOCUSED ON FREEDOM, THE ECONOMY,
FORWARD-LOOKING ISSUES.
THOSE ARE THE CANDIDATES HAVING
MORE SUCCESS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
GOING FORWARD IN TO 2024.
THE CANDIDATES THAT HAVE A PLAN
FOR WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO TO
MAKE THINGS BETTER RATHER THAN
SAY HOW BAD THINGS ARE AND WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE IT WHAT IT USED TO
BE.
>> Neil: IT WASN'T THAT LONG
AGO, TOM, THAT THE PRESIDENT,
DONALD TRUMP, WAS TELLING
REPUBLICANS THAT HE MIGHT
CONSIDER PRESIDENTIAL RUNS OF
THEIR OWN THAT IT WOULD NOT BE
THE HONORABLE THING TO DO SEEING
THAT HE WAS RUNNING.
AND MANY MIGHT HAVE THEN AND
STILL NOW HELD OFF BECAUSE OF
THAT.
LESS SO NOW?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT LESS SO
NOW.
I THINK THIS ELECTION -- HAD
THIS BEEN A REPUBLICAN WAVE, HAD
A LOT OF THESE TRUMP-BACKED
CANDIDATES WON, IT WOULD BE A
DIFFERENT DYNAMIC.
BIDEN WOULD BE UNDER A LOT OF
PRESSURE TO NOT RUN IN 2024.
IT'S DEFINITELY OPENED THE DOOR
FOR DESANTIS AND OTHER
CANDIDATES THAT WERE EMBOLDENED
BY THIS.
HERSCHEL WALKER WAS A FLAWED
CANDIDATE.
EVERYBODY KNEW THAT.
I DON'T THINK THIS LOSS HURTS
TRUMP AS MUCH AS HIS OWN -- HIS
OTHER SELF-INFLICTED WOUNDS AND
HIS TWEET ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION, HIS MEETING WITH
KANYE AND NICK FUENTES.
FOR PEOPLE THAT LIKE TRUMP
POLICIES BUT DON'T LIKE TRUMP
THE PERSONA OR ALL OF THE
BAGGAGE THAT HE BRINGS TO THE
TABLE, THOSE ARE GREAT EXCUSES,
GREAT DATA POINTS FOR THEM TO
MOVE AWAY FROM TRUMP AND LOOK